acculé par ses problèmes financiers
Hugues aurait pris rendez-vous avec sa
mère elle lui aurait ouvert sans se
méfier et il l'aurait poignardé la
théorie des enquêteurs semble se tenir
un détail près un détail de poids
nous sommes le 31 décembre 1996 à
Brison-Saint-Innocent un petit village
savoyard situé au bord du lac du Bourget
tout près d'Aix-les-Bains
[Musique]
il est 8h du matin le soleil se lève à
peine mais un homme se dirige déjà vers
son lieu de travail c'est Daniel
principe le jardinier d'une riche veuve
du village Anne-Marie Pignal 76 ans
elle vit dans cette demeure située un
peu en retrait du village
le jardinier Daniel principe ouvre la
porte de la maison de sa patronne
Anne-Marie Pignal
et là entre l'entrée et la cuisine il
tombe sur le corps inanimé de sa
patronne qui vit sur le dos un couteau
planté dans le thorax à la région du
cœur
en se rapprochant Daniel principe
s'aperçoit que la septua génère n'est
pas morte son jardinier me demande si
elle a eu un si c'est un accident ou si
elle a été agressée elle ne répond pas
immédiatement le jardinier prévient des
secours
quelques minutes plus tard à 8h20 les
pompiers arrivent à la Résidence
d'Anne-Marie Pignan
[Musique]
le pouls de la vieille dame est lent
mais elles ne semble pas avoir perdu
beaucoup de sang
[Musique]
les sauveteurs décident d'ailleurs de ne
pas retirer le couteau afin d'éviter
tout risque d'hémorragie
le couteau bougeait au rythme des
pulsations cardiaques il était juste
collé contre le cœur
Anne-Marie Pignal toujours consciente et
emmenée sur une civière
dans le véhicule qui la conduit à
l'hôpital les pompiers vont effectuer
une transfusion sanguine pour lui
permettre de retrouver une tension
artérielle correcte
et la victime retrouve la force de
parler et voici ce qu'elle confie au
sauveteur
j'attendais mon fils quelqu'un a frappé
à la porte je pensais que c'était lui je
ne me suis pas méfiée j'ai ouvert on m'a
sauté dessus on m'a attrapé le coup je
ne pourrais pas décrire mes agresseurs
mais ils étaient au moins deux
[Musique]
à 8h45 l'ambulance transportant
Anne-Marie Pigna arrive au centre
hospitalier de Chambéry
les médecins décident de réaliser en
urgence une ablation du poumon gauche
qui a été sévèrement touché
seulement après deux heures
d'intervention Anne-Marie Pignal décès
au bloc opératoire il est 10h42
au même moment à Brison-Saint-Innocent
les gendarmes inspectent la scène de
crime
recherche d'empreintes de trace ADN ou
de tout autre indice pouvant les
conduire sur une piste il ne doivent pas
perdre une seule seconde
mais enquêtes en général elles se gagne
ou elle se perdent dans les premières
heures la piste que privilégie les
enquêteurs et celles d'un crime
crapuleux il faut dire qu'elle Marie
Pignal était riche très riche
milliardaire même son défunt mari Félix
Pignal n'était autre que le PDG dit à
chiffrance un homme réputé pour sa
générosité
la famille pignale était très
honorablement connue à
Brison-Saint-Innocent monsieur Pignal
avant son décès en 92 avait fait
beaucoup de choses pour la commune et en
particulier avait donné la somme de 1
million de francs de l'époque pour
construire une résidence pour personnes
âgées cette résidence existe toujours et
porte toujours son nom
et justement cette richesse connue de
tous a très bien pu attirer des
convoitises
la fortune de Madame Pignal s'entraîne
vie la maison qu'elle occupée
attirait forcément des visiteurs entre
guillemets et depuis quelques mois les
forces de l'ordre sont confrontées à une
série de cambriolages envers les
retraités de la région c'est donc tout
naturellement la piste que vont
favoriser les enquêteurs précisément au
cours du dernier trimestre 96 il y a eu
un certain nombre d'agressions de
personnes âgées et nous on s'est quand
même interrogé sur la similitude de du
mode d'agression
pourtant lors de la perquisition de la
maison plusieurs éléments étonnent les
gendarmes d'ailleurs le patron de
l'enquête le capitaine manuel Noguerra
commence à mettre en doute la thèse du
cambriolage
il n'y a pas eu des fractions aucune
Fouine est constaté nous découvrons même
sur sa table de chevet une somme de 6000
francs en espèces qui n'a pas été qui
n'a pas été dérobé
les constatations réalisées dans tout le
reste de la maison dans toutes les
pièces démontent qu'il n'a eu aucune
fouille ce qui a semble un peu bizarre
nous c'est que rien n'était dérobé
maintenant c'est vrai que l'hypothèse
qui ont rien été dérobée avec la
personne a peut-être été dérangée
dérangée notamment par l'arrivée de
Monsieur principe ce matin là
la faute d'éléments les gendarmes
écartent donc la piste du vol qui a mal
tourné et partent à la recherche de
nouveaux indices autour d'Anne-Marie
Pignal qui pouvait lui en vouloir si ce
n'est pas un crime de rôdeur qui pouvait
en vouloir à Madame
pour relancer l'enquête légendaire mise
beaucoup sur les résultats des premières
analyses scientifiques mais une série de
négligences et de malchances valeurs
compliquée la tâche il se trouve que il
y avait une madame Pignal qui était
mourante les secours sont arrivés c'est
normal on a essayé de sauver cette dame
qui était en train de malheureusement de
mourir sous les yeux d'un grand nombre
de personnes
mais on a pris aucune précaution d'abord
les enquêteurs comptent sur les traces
conduit forcément laisser les agresseurs
autour de la maison
il se trouve que ce 31 décembre il avait
neigé pas mal il y avait entre 2 et 5 cm
autour de la maison de neige pourtant
contre toute attente ces traces vont se
révéler totalement inexploitables
la neige qui revêtait le jardin de la
maison était souillé de toutes les
empreintes de pas des secours alors que
normalement il y avait les empreintes de
pas de celui ou de ceux qui étaient
venus tuer madame Pignal les gendarmes
espèrent alors que l'expertise de l'arme
du crime leur permettent d'en savoir
plus mais là encore en vain car une fois
retirée du thorax d'Anne-Marie Pignal à
l'hôpital le couteau a été stérilisé on
n'avait pas pris les précautions
fondamentales qui auraient normalement
dû préserver les éventuels traces sur le
manche c'est une négligence de la part
de l'hôpital
qui ne servait pas que c'est une mes
banques quand on voit arriver quelqu'un
avec un couteau planté dans le dans le
thorax on doit bien se douter que c'est
pas forcément accidentel
donc il y a quelques précautions qui
doivent être prises bon on avait
peut-être à faire des infirmiers ou une
infirmière un peu trop novice autre
déception les experts scientifiques ont
trouvé un cheveu sur une nappe saisie au
domicile d'Anne-Marie Pignal un cheveu
qui n'appartient pas à la victime mais
les procédures n'ont pas été respectées
et ce cheveu s'avèrent lui aussi
inexploitable de la même manière la
scène de crimes n'ayant pas été protégée
aucune des empreintes digitales relevées
ne peut être utilisée
sur la scène de crime il n'y a aucun
indice matériel ou aucune trace qui
permette de d'identifier le ou les
auteurs de l'agression seul indice
fourni par l'expertise balistique la
taille de la graisseur
une atteinte effectuée par un agresseur
de taille supérieure à sa victime
l'ennui C4 Mary Pignal ne mesure aucun
mètre 53 et donc son agresseur ressemble
forcément à monsieur tout le monde
pas de trace de pas pas d'empreinte
aucun ADN les enquêteurs ne possèdent
pas le moindre indice l'affaire
s'annonce particulièrement difficile
mais les résultats de l'autopsie et les
témoignages de quelques voisins vont
leur permettre de reconstituer en partie
les dernières heures de la vie
d'Anne-Marie Pignan
[Musique]
une chose est sûre la victime était
réveillée à l'heure du crime une voisine
confirme avoir vu la lumière s'allumer
dans la maison d'Anne-Marie Pignal entre
7h et 7h15 comme à son habitude la
victime a ouvert ses volets et s'est
habillé
enfin comme La Teste l'autopsie
Anne-Marie a dû prendre son petit
déjeuner
personne n'a vu les agresseurs mais le
meurtre a forcément eu lieu entre le
réveil d'Anne-Marie Pignal et l'arrivée
de Daniel principe soit entre 7 heures
et 8h du matin
les enquêteurs disposent de très peu
d'éléments simplement une petite plage
horaire pendant laquelle le crime a
forcément été commis
ultime information pour les enquêteurs
des riverains ont entendu une voiture
longer la maison d'Anne-Marie Pignal
vers 7h30
il y a une voisine et un voisin
également ils ont tous les deux bien
entendu une voiture venir le matin très
très tôt mais ils n'ont pas apporté
d'éléments tangibles pas de couleur de
voiture pas de marque et puis après plus
de traces
à cette étape de l'enquête les gendarmes
sont dans l'impasse on balaye assez
larges toutes les toutes les pistes
possibles
surtout quand on a aucun élément aucun
élément matériel à ce moment-là tout de
suite à se mettre sous la dent
parmi les suspects possibles Daniel le
jardinier après tout c'est lui qui a
découvert le corps
l'homme est interrogé et il va faire une
révélation à propos de l'arme du crime
le jardinier quand il est interrogé par
les enquêteurs juste après leur arrivée
il connaît il va dire qu'il connaît très
bien l'arme du crime
il s'agit d'un couteau à pain et à
décongélation qui se trouve donc dans un
tiroir de la cuisine seulement le
jardinier semble dévaster par la mort de
la vieille dame il s'entendait très bien
avec elle et puis il a appelé les
secours alors qu'elle était encore en
vie rapidement les enquêteurs décident
de le mettre hors de cause le jardin
était quelqu'un qui n'était un homme mal
à la personnalité tout à fait ordinaire
au bon sens du terme donc non il n'y a
pas eu de recherche particulière faite
dans cette direction et il n'y avait
sans doute pas forcément en faire les
enquêteurs ne disposent d'aucun indice
mais il leur reste une piste à exploiter
dans l'ambulance qu'il a transporté à
l'hôpital
Anne-Marie Pignal a eu le temps de dire
qu'elle attendait son fils
alors il est temps pour les enquêteurs
de s'intéresser de plus près à lui
dans les jours qui suivent les gendarmes
auditionnent voisins amis et membres de
la famille d'Anne-Marie Pignal il
s'intéresse plus particulièrement à ses
deux enfants sa fille d'abord qui est
une fille qu'elle a adoptée en 1961 une
fille qui est mariée qui a elle-même des
enfants qui vit simplement c'est une
femme sans histoire d'après les éléments
du dossier elle était rigoureuse dans la
gestion elle tenait sa famille elle est
tout à fait normalement et il y avait
pas de difficultés elle avait de très
bonne relation avec sa mère sa mère la
voyait régulièrement elle s'entendent
parfaitement bien et leur relation ont
toujours été au beau fixe du côté de son
frère Hugues les choses sont plus
compliquées entre discothèque bar et
Casino depuis plusieurs années il mène
un train de vie bien au-dessus de ses
moyens
oui c'était un personnage et qui aimait
s'entourer de
gens de la nuit qui qui sortaient
énormément qui dépensaient beaucoup
pignole ça n'était pas un secret était
quelqu'un d'extrêmement dépensier il
avait dépensé les sommes fabuleuses il
menait un train de vie extravagant
il y avait une générosité pour
tous ce cercle amical c'est un homme
fort engueule qui a et qui a de la
gouaille qui fréquente des gens pas
toujours très recommandables il est
beaucoup dans les milieux de la nuit
dans les bars de nuit les discothèques
ils fréquentent beaucoup les milieux
interlopes de d'Aix-les-Bains et des
petits voyous qui sont parfois connus de
la police seulement les gendarmes vont
découvrir que ce comportement très
dépensier n'est pas sans conséquence
Hugues Pignal connaît de très gros
problèmes d'argent il était au moment
des faits dans une situation dramatique
sur le plan financier
il a des emprunts qui n'a pas remboursé
des emprunts à des particuliers qu'il a
fait à des particuliers 60000 francs
pour l'un 35000 francs pour l'autre
50 personnels sont sont largement
débiteurs il est interdit de checker
tout comme ça tout comme ça concubine ça
paraît ça paraît fou depuis deux ans HUG
Pigna les propriétaires d'un club de
squash à Viviers-du-Lac un petit village
sur les rives du lac du Bourget mais le
club est au bord de la faillite au total
Pignal a accumulé près de 200 000 francs
de loyer de retard soit 30000 euros et
ce n'est pas tout
il était très endetté à travers des des
pensions alimentaires qui devaient
verser à ces deux premières femmes avec
qui il avait eu respectivement deux et
un enfant une situation financière
d'autant plus dure à expliquer qu'à la
mort de son père en 1992 le fils a
touché 6 millions de francs d'héritage
près d'un million d'euros une somme
colossale qu'il a dilapidé en moins de 5
ans
Island d'ailleurs il nous l'a dit
l'argent lui brûle les doigts autant sa
soeur avait préservé cette somme en la
plaçant et en vivant en vivant des
intérêts que lui procurer ces 6 millions
francs lui upinial c'était en pressé de
les dépenser vraiment par la chatte
d'une maison en fin de la construction
d'une maison à punishment une maison
maison de luxe des achats de véhicules
de luxe Porsche des motos bateau
des voyages divers par exemple après son
deuxième divorce il va épouser Viviane
et il va emmener la quarantaine de
convives en Corse à Porto-Vecchio pour
fêter le mariage et il va les emmener
assez frais en avion en Corse monsieur
Félix Pignal
avait dit en parlant de son fils de
toute façon après moi il vous fera tout
en cette fin d'année 1996 huppignal a
donc de gros problèmes d'argent
et pourtant les gendarmes vont découvrir
que l'un de ces comptes bancaires
s'élève à 12 millions de francs
problème il n'est pas le seul titulaire
de ce conte sa mère Anne-Marie Pignal en
conserve l'usufruit et elle peut donc
disposer comme elle veut en attendant sa
mort Hugues n'a donc qu'une seule
solution pour profiter de cet argent
obtenir l'accord de sa mère et le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'il se
montre insistant quand elle voulait elle
voyait upignal il se fixait rendez-vous
par écrit ou par téléphone et elle
notait le rendez-vous elle prévenait le
jardinier chaque fois qu'elle avait
rendez-vous avec une pinéale il n'avait
de cesse après de harceler sa mère pour
lui soutirer de l'argent et elle l'avait
déjà donné des sommes fantastiques elle
a régulièrement épongé les dettes de son
fils même si elle aurait souhaité ne pas
le faire pour pas que le nom de Pignal
soit sali par les dépenses et les
ardoises que l'essai upignal un peu
partout et Hugues Pignal ne supportait
pas de devoir en quelque sorte supplier
sa mère pour avoir de l'argent au fil du
les relations entre la mer et le fils
deviennent de plus en plus houleuses
pour preuve cette lettre que nous nous
sommes procurés daté du 6 janvier 1995
rédigé par Anne-Marie à l'attention de
Hugues
bonjour Hugues qui est toujours mon fils
[Musique]
comment te rendre crédible alors que tu
cherches à Aix à te faire passer pour un
cahier de fortuné qui roule les épaules
[Musique]
je t’en prie ne continue pas ainsi ni
ton père ni moi ne t'avons donné un tel
exemple je compte encore sur toi et
embrasse maternellement ce qui n'exclut
pas le désaveu de tes attitudes
une telle animosité pourrait-elle
justifier le crime
3 janvier 1997 gendarmerie de Chambéry
les enquêteurs auditionnent Hugues
bignal et alors grande surprise dès les
premières minutes l'homme de cache pas
ses ennuis bancaires
[Musique]
dis-moi une confiance qu'il est très
dépensier qu'il devait qu'il devait de
l'argent et que
grâce au compte individu mais il va
pouvoir
combler ses dettes
les gendarmes demandent ensuite à Hugues
bignal de détailler son emploi du temps
le jour du meurtre
quand les enquêteurs vont l'interroger
pour savoir où il était le 31 décembre
1996 au petit matin
upinial n'hésite pas
Hugues confirme qu'il avait bien
rendez-vous avec sa mère ce matin-là il
devait lui faire signer des papiers et
récupérer des cartons dans son garage il
était prévu qu'il passait elle entre 8h
et 9h et voici ce qu'il dit d'avoir fait
auparavant
ce serait réveillé à 7h dans sa maison
située sur les hauteurs d'Aix-les-Bains
il aurait pris sa voiture un véhicule de
type 205 commercial blanche pour se
rendre dans le centre d'Aix-Les-Bains
avenue du Grand Port à moins de 10
minutes de chez lui il se serait d'abord
arrêter à la boulangerie pour acheter
des pains au chocolat puis à la Maison
de la presse pour acheter le journal
d'ailleurs il aurait croisé une
connaissance incertain Stéphane Chabanne
quelques instants après il aurait pris
un café au bar du soleil
il fait état d'une conversation qu'il a
entendu dans un bar où il a pris un café
donc il a comme ça un certain nombre de
il est capable de donner un timing très
précis de cette matinée enfin Hugues
Pignal serait rentré chez lui vers 7h45
et ce serait recoucher quelques minutes
son épouse Viviane le confirmera au
gendarme elle ajoutera d'ailleurs que
son mari aurait été réveillé par le coup
de téléphone paniqué de sa sœur Hélène
sa sœur qui
indique que Madame Pignal
s'est blessé et qui lui arrivait quelque
chose de grave voilà les gendarmes
décident de vérifier l'emploi du temps
dugpingle il part à la rencontre
d'éventuelles témoin
il fallait faire la lumière sur sur les
lieux où il s'était vraiment rendu ce
matin là et vérifie ses habits
mais rapidement les enquêteurs
découvrent que peu de personnes se
souviennent de la présence du Pignal au
matin du 31 décembre
ni la boulangère
ni le marchand de journaux ni même le
tenon si du bar du soleil ne sont
réellement certains de l'avoir vu toutes
ces déclarations sont
très contradictoires
chaque fois qu'il dit quelque chose il y
a quelqu'un pour intervenir pour dire le
contraire pourtant un homme confirme
avoir croisé pignale ce matin-là vers
7h10 c'est Stéphane Chabanne l'homme qui
l'a rencontré devant le marchand de
journaux la Libye est maigre certes mais
pour les gendarmes il existe il n'aurait
pas eu d'alibi c'est pas quelque chose
que je trouvais très important dans le
dossier
parce que sur les horaires vous savez on
passe pas à regarder sa montre le
témoignage visuel est quand même très
fragile les commerçants peuvent la voir
il a pu être là avec le commerçant s'en
souvient plus dans le pour moi c'était
pas quelque chose favorable au
défavorable qui avait de l'importance
dans le dossier l'incertitude quant à
son alibi n'est pas suffisant aux yeux
des enquêteurs évidemment pour espérer
accuser une pinial ou même tout
simplement le placer en garde à vue et
le confondre dans le crime qu'il tente
de lucider alors les gendarmes laissent
donc Pignal en liberté tout en
continuant à enquêter sur lui et
rapidement ils vont se rendre compte que
depuis quelques temps ces problèmes
financiers se sont particulièrement
aggravés
en passant les contes Duke Pignal à la
loupe les gendarmes découvrent deux
informations capitales la première
séquence est fin d'année 1996 l'homme a
reçu deux sommations d'huissiers lui
réclamant un total de 200000 francs
c'était le 30 décembre
1996 la veille du meurtre ils apprennent
aussi que les relations entre Anne-Marie
Pignal et son fils étaient devenus si
tendu que celle-ci avait pour projet de
le déshériter en partie
sa mère
on avait assez des dépenses de son fils
et vous l'êtes pas tout moyen essayez de
freiner ses dépenses il y avait des
tensions
Anne-Marie Pignal qui était une femme de
caractère
extrêmement bonne gestionnaire
puisqu'elle avait en charge la gestion
de toute cette fortune accumulée pendant
des années de travail
par le père Pignal
c'est vrai que ça c'était elle était
confrontée à un personnage qu'elle
devait considérer comme étant
irresponsable et notamment elle avait
envisagé de modifier le testament
qui était en sa faveur pour donner une
partie de sa fortune non pas à son fils
mais à ses petits-enfants à ça lui
l'avait appris et ça l'avait
véritablement contrarié plus incroyable
encore les enquêteurs découvrent
kukpigna la dépense et une partie
importante de l'héritage de sa mère
quelques jours à peine après l'avoir
touché
il avait besoin d'argent frais donc il y
a eu l'héritage qui est arrivé et comme
par hasard ces affaires qui
périclitaient
on commençait et aller un petit mieux
parce qu'il a un petit peu mieux parce
qu'il a remboursé un certain nombre de
choses et en particulier il y avait ce
squash donc il s'occupait à
Viviers-du-Lac et comme par hasard
pratiquement du jour au lendemain le
squash n'était plus à vendre
face à ces éléments les gendarmes
pensent avoir trouvé le mobile parfait
et ils imaginent un scénario possible
acculé par ses problèmes financiers
Hugues aurait pris rendez-vous avec sa
mère prétextant des papiers à signer et
des cartons à déménager le 31 décembre
elle lui aurait ouvert sans se méfier et
il l'aurait poignardé la théorie des
enquêteurs semble se tenir un détail
près un détail de poids
si Hugues Pignal a agressé sa mère
pourquoi ne l'a-t-elle pas dénoncé dans
l'ambulance
Anne-Marie Pignal quand elle a parlé au
médecin
urgentiste mais également à son
jardinier n'a jamais cité le nom de du
Pignal il y aurait été facile de dire
que parmi les agresseurs se trouvaient
son propre fils donc on a déjà un
premier élément absolument évident c'est
que la victime elle-même ne n'accuse pas
son fils
les gendarmes ne disposent d'aucune
preuve matérielle ni de témoignage
direct pendant plusieurs mois l'enquête
piétine et c'est grâce au hasard que
l'affaire va être relancé
mais 1997 les gendarmes de Chambéry
entendent un certain Philippe couvert
pour une affaire de stupéfiants à faire
qui a priori n'a rien à voir avec le
meurtre d'Anne-Marie Pignal Philippe
couvert c'est un petit escroc qui est
déjà eu des soucis pour vol également et
il est placé en garde à vue donc dans le
cadre de cette petite affaire et il
espère pouvoir tirer son épingle du jeu
c'est à dire que très vite il dit aux
enquêteurs moi j'ai des révélations à
vous faire sur l'assassinat de Madame
Pignal Philippe couvert commence par
expliquer qu'il connaît le fils de
Madame Pignal puisqu'ils ont été en
relation d'affaires Philippe couvert
connaît bien uppinial pour avoir été
gérant quelques années auparavant du
club de squash détenu par huppignal mais
Philippe couvert explique surtout que
par hasard dans un bar il a surpris une
conversation suspecte entre Hugues
Pignal et un autre homme Patrick Balan
et derrière lui depuis longtemps il
reconnaît les voix de Hugues Pignal et
de Patrick Balan deux amis à lui Patrick
Balan disant à huppinial tu as vu ce que
tu m'as fait faire et tu m'as mis dans
une galère cette dispute avait-elle un
lien avec la mort d'Anne-Marie Pignal et
qui est ce Patrick Balan avec qui Hulk
Pignal s'entretenait les gendarmes n'ont
jamais entendu parler de Patrick Balan
ils ne savent pas qu'il est alors
évidemment ils vont se renseigner sur
lui ils apprennent que c'est un ancien
portier de de discothèque fort en gueule
qui aime bien aussi fréquenter les
milieux de la nuit et dépenser de
dépenser de l'argent un peu sans compter
un peu à la façon du du Pignal mais sans
sans le côté flamboyant que peut avoir
huppinial à travers ses dépenses mais
lors de son interrogatoire avec les
gendarmes Philippe couvert ne va pas
s'arrêter là il va faire des révélations
beaucoup plus direct par la suite
Patrick Balan reverra couvert et couvert
lui demandera pourquoi
eu cette dispute entre ukpignan et toi
il dira mais j'étais j'étais avec Pignal
quand il a tué sa mère ce matin là
et il m'a mis dans la galère
pour la première fois depuis le début de
l'enquête les gendarmes ont enfin de
quoi accusé Pignal mais peuvent-ils se
fier aux témoignage de Philippe couvert
petit escroc qui semble ne pas porter
Hugues dans son cœur dans ce dossier on
a que des personnalités qui sortent un
peu l'ordinaire on a ce monsieur couvert
dont on sait qu'il a un conflit très vif
avec Monsieur Pignal je crois qu'il se
déteste et oui puisque Pignal avait
racheté le squash
donc il y avait un conflit d'intérêt
économie que ils sont connus
s'agit-il d'une simple vengeance entre
deux concurrents Philippe couvert
accuse-t-il à tort les deux hommes pour
le savoir une seule solution confrontée
pignale
3 juin 1997 Hugues Pignal et Patrick
Balan sont convoqués à la gendarmerie de
Chambéry
interroger les deux hommes réfutent
entièrement le récit de Philippe couvert
d'ailleurs à les en croire il ne se
connaissent même pas
c'est vrai que pour eux il n'y a
pratiquement pas de lien entre eux ils
ne se connaissent pas ils se fréquent
tout juste et face aux gendarmes qui ne
savent plus qui croire HUG Pignal
retourne l'accusation
[Musique]
une pignale va même d'ailleurs aller
jusqu'à dire que Philippe couvert est
vraisemblablement le meurtrier le bras
armé qui qui a tué sa mère faute de
preuves les gendarmes sont bien obligés
de laisser repartir Pignal et Balan
donc avec le magistral sinon de lever la
garde à vue puisque nous n'avons pas
plus d'éléments concernant le dossier
l'affaire l'agression de Madame Pignal
mais ils ne vont pas baisser les bras
pour autant non seulement les deux
suspects sont placés sur écoute mais ils
vont être pris en filature et surveillés
c'est ainsi que les gendarmes vont
découvrir que Pigna les ballons qui
affirmaient ne pas se connaître semble
temps réalité inséparable
et à partir de ce moment-là c'est vrai
que nous constatons que Patrick Balan et
Pignal ne se lâche plus
il sorte ensemble régulièrement
ils partent en vacances ensemble
régulièrement
impression que la garde à vue les a
libérés de quelque chose
soit il pense qu'ils ne sont plus
surveillés
la garde à vue les a rapprochés plutôt
pour la première
solution en fait des gendarmes vont
comprendre très vite que ces deux hommes
là se connaissent de longue date mais
qu'ils avaient gardé leur relation
secrète pourquoi leur est-il gardé
secret est-ce que c'est parce que elle
est en lien avec l'assassinat
d'Anne-Marie Pignal et les enquêteurs à
cette époque s'interrogent encore
bignole et ballons se connaissent depuis
très longtemps les gendarmes en sont
désormais persuadés mais une énigme
subsiste pourquoi ont-ils caché leur
amitié ils obtiendront la réponse grâce
à un troisième homme
les gendarmes le savent le téléphone est
l'un des moyens les plus faciles pour
piéger un suspect il décide donc de
fouiller dans les relevés téléphoniques
de Patrick Balan le résultat ne se fait
pas attendre il concerne le jour du
meurtre d'Anne-Marie Pignal donc le 31
décembre 96 à 6h45 un appel est émis
depuis le domicile donc de Patrick Balan
vers un numéro qui s'avéra être un
numéro tattoo et c'est un appareil un
récepteur sur lequel on peut recevoir un
numéro de téléphone Patrick Balan depuis
son domicile contact un certain
Jean-Claude Hardy il lui envoie un
message sur un travail secteur tattoo
comme s'il s'agissait d'un peu d'un
réveil matin
Jean-Claude Hardy
les gendarmes se renseignent sur ce
trentenaire un ex videur de discothèque
au casier judiciaire vierge
c'est quelqu'un de simple de paisible de
serein on décrit par ailleurs dans le
dossier comme quelqu'un de sportif de la
musculation c'est vrai qu'il a la chance
d'avoir un physique costaud alors
effectivement il a pu travailler comme
portier dans une boîte de nuit parce que
dans le milieu d'Aix ben il y a des
boîtes de nuit ce genre d'individus
parce qu'on y connaît ballant il connaît
d'autres a pu travailler dans ce secteur
il a fait plusieurs petits boulots mais
encore une fois sans conduite
délinquante avérée dans un premier temps
les enquêteurs décident de ne pas
interpeller cet homme ils veulent
continuer à l'observer sans qu'il ne se
doute de rien parallèlement ils
épluchent ces relevés bancaires et
apparemment Jean-Claude Hardy a des
goûts de luxe ils vont s'apercevoir là
que Jean-Claude Hardy vit lui aussi un
peu au-dessus de ses moyens notamment il
va partir en vacances aux Antilles avec
sa compagne et aussi il dépense de
l'argent un peu remonter en tout cas
bien au-delà de ce qu'il peut gagner en
sa qualité de portier de nuit il a fait
deux séjours en Martinique alors que
lui-même ne travaille pas d'où
Jean-Claude Hardy tire cet argent les
enquêteurs vont découvrir quelque chose
d'étonnant l'homme reçoit régulièrement
des enveloppes de la part de Patrick
Balan des enveloppes remplies de billets
le calcul ou les rapprochements et les
aveux des uns et des autres sur ce point
permettent de dire que Monsieur Hardy
aura touché entre 70 et 100 000 francs
de l'époque en une dizaine d'enveloppes
en espèces qu'il dépensait au fur et à
mesure pourquoi ballon remet-il de
l'argent à Hardy et quel est le lien
entre les deux hommes et Hugues Pignal
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas de lien
direct entre Jean-Claude Hardy
et ukinium on sait qu'ils ont des
relations ensemble que de l'argent passe
demain en main mais on ne sait pas qui
fait quoi et à quel moment encore une
fois c'est un appel téléphonique qui va
donner un coup de pouce aux enquêteurs
[Musique]
nous sommes le 11 octobre 1999 les
gendarmes savent que Jean-Claude Hardy
est venu passer le week-end dans un
hôtel du centre ville de Chambéry pour
eux le moment est venu de l'interpeller
nous interpellons Jean-Claude
donc là c'est tous les deux en garde à
vue emmener à la gendarmerie de Chambéry
Jean-Claude Hardy commence par nier
catégoriquement tout implication dans le
meurtre d'Anne-Marie Pignal les
enquêteurs l’interrogent alors sur les
sommes d'argent que lui a remis Patrick
Balan et là encore il ne se démonte pas
il trouve immédiatement une explication
l'argent que me fournissait ballon
provenait d'un trafic de drogue
il va d'abord dire que ils sont liés à
un trafic de drogue on comprend aisément
que Jean-Claude Hardy préfère
s'impliquer dans un trafic de drogue
plutôt que de dire qu'il a
éventuellement participé à un crime les
gendarmes vont alors faire écouter à
Jean-Claude Hardy l'enregistrement de
l'appel qu'il a passé à Viviane Pignal
et là Hardy comprend qu'il est piégé
là il craque
il nous demande à pouvoir parler à sa
concubine Sophie diabeck
pouvoir l'embrasser une dernière fois
donc là on se dit qu'il a des
révélations à nous faire donc
effectivement nous acceptons qu'il
puisse embrasser une dernière fois
Sophie
j'écoute moi ce qui lui dit de manière
proche il dit tu sais j'y suis pour rien
j'y suis pour rien et l'embrasse
plusieurs fois et il se met à pleurer
comme elle elle ne comprend pas
et là il s'explique voici ce que
Jean-Claude Hardy explique aux
enquêteurs Patrick Balland m'a demandé
un ou deux jours avant le 31 décembre si
j'étais intéressé pour participer à un
déménagement ce jour-là il est venu me
chercher de bonheur dans une voiture
commerciale blanche
ensuite Hardy explique que ballon
n'était pas seul ce matin-là mais il
n'apprendra l'identité de l'inconnu que
bien plus tard Jean-Claude Hardy ne sait
pas qui l'accompagne il sait que Patrick
Balan est dans le véhicule mais il ne
sait pas qui est l'homme qui est
derrière le volant cet homme qui est
derrière le volant c'est eupignal
mais lui ne l'a jamais rencontré à cette
époque là Jean-Claude Hardy raconte
qu'il est ensuite conduit par les deux
hommes vers une destination inconnue
emmener devant une maison
dans la banlieue d'Aix ne connaît pas
les lieux Patrick Balan et lui-même ont
attendu à l'extérieur pendant que le 3e
individu frappait à la porte était reçu
par une dame de certaines âges qui était
nul lui ouvrir
et Monsieur Hardy nous dit
j'ai entendu des éclats de voix
ce monsieur est rentré avec la dame à
l'intérieur de la propriété nous sommes
restés à l'extérieur à attendre quelques
instants les éclats de voix ont perdurer
puis un silence ce qu'ils a poussé donc
à rentrer rapidement dans
dans la maison
[Musique]
mon client me suit Hardy voit une dame
au sol avec un couteau planté dans la
poitrine
et l'individu qui était à côté d'elle
disait c'est un accident c'est un
accident
il faut partir il faut partir c'est un
accident et je me suis Ardi a toujours
indiqué pour moi elle était morte elle
avait les yeux et le sait complètement
inconsciente pour moi elle était morte
donc il quitte rapidement les lieux il
remonte dans ce véhicule
l'individu reprend le volant balant je
suis ma mémoire est bonne place
passagère
l'individu que mon client ne connaissait
pas
était énervé taper sur le volant en
disant c'est un accident c'est un
accident personne ne va nous croire
personne ne nous a vu c'est un accident
c'était un accident bordel c'était un
accident
vous ne dites rien à personne je crois
qu'il leur a dit je vous en tout cas ça
s'est révélé plus tard je vous
indemniserai pour votre silence au total
Jean-Claude Hardy explique avoir touché
près de 100.000 francs de la part de
Pignan par l'intermédiaire de balance
les enquêteurs n'en reviennent pas le
videur vient de leur apporter le
témoignage qu'ils attendaient depuis
deux ans les enquêteurs retiennent
vraiment c'est le vraiment le coup de
théâtre puisque les enquêteurs tiennent
vraiment une piste sérieuse et en tout
cas suffisamment d'éléments pour
inquiéter
ukinial et par ricochet Patrick Balan
dans les 48 heures qui suivent les
enquêteurs vont interroger Balan puis
pignale mais face à ces deux hommes qui
nie fermement tout implication dans le
meurtre et en l'absence de preuve les
gendarmes sont obligés de les libérer
ils ont été remis en liberté par la
chambre de l'instruction estime que il y
avait des gages de représentation et que
il pouvait attendre en liberté que le
procès d'assise intervienne cela va
faire près de 3 ans quel Mary Pignal a
été assassiné on pense que cette
histoire est terminée mais un homme va
donner une nouvelle version des faits
10 mars 2000 plusieurs mois après son
premier témoignage Balan et de nouveau
entendu par la gendarmerie de Chambéry
et il va changer radicalement de
discours il reconnaît avoir remis des
enveloppes plein d'argent à hardi mais
en aucun cas pour commettre un meurtre
il ne s'agit que d'un service qu'il
aurait rendu à son ami Pignal il dit que
un déménagement était prévu ce jour-là
et que lui a servi d'intermédiaire en
fait entre upinial et Jean-Claude Hardy
Jean-Claude Hardy qui était censé donner
un coup de main à Épinal pour le
déménagement lui n'aurait fait
finalement que alerter par sur son tatou
Jean-Claude Hardy pour qu'il n'oublie
pas de se rendre au rendez-vous il lit
s'être déplacé aux côtés de Jean-Claude
Hardy et duc pinéal le matin du crime
seulement après vérification de ces
relevés téléphoniques cette version ne
tient pas
[Musique]
très vite les enquêteurs vont vont
réussir à démontrer que
Patrick Balan ne dit pas la vérité
parce que il n'a pas reçu le coup de fil
ce matin-là de piniale même s'il ne
donne pas les mêmes versions des faits
Jean-Claude Hardy et Patrick Balan sont
d'accord sur un point l'implication du
Pignal dans la mort de sa mère
les gendarmes pensent enfin avoir
compris ce qui s'est passé et voici leur
hypothèse
la veille du meurtre le 30 décembre 1996
Hugues Pignal reçoit deux sommations
d'huissiers il doit 200 000 francs il
est ruiné et il sait qu'il va perdre son
club de squash
comme à chaque fois qu'il a besoin
d'argent il se tourne vers sa mère il
l'appelle pour prendre rendez-vous pour
le lendemain
le 31 décembre à 6h45
Patrick Balan contact Jean-Claude Hardy
puis le récupère devant chez lui dans
une voiture conduite par HUG Pignal
une fois arrivé à Brison-Saint-Innocent
Hugues sonne à la porte de sa mère
celle-ci n'attend son fils qu'une heure
plus tard elle se méfie et ouvre un
couteau à la main
Hugues pénètre dans la maison il lui
demande de l'argent mais sa mère refuse
de lui en donner
il se dispute
l'échange dégénère et c'est à ce moment
qu'il se saisit du couteau et la
poignarde
[Musique]
alerter ses complices le rejoignent
croyant Anne-Marie Pignan morte il
décide de prendre la fuite
[Musique]
Hugues Pignal raccompagne les deux
hommes puis vers 7h10 ils seront dans le
centre d'Aix-Les-Bains pour se
construire un alibi il achète des pains
au chocolat et le journal heureux hasard
il croise son ami Stéphane Chabanne
il rentre chez lui vers 8h avant de
recevoir le coup de téléphone de sa sœur
10 minutes plus tard grâce à cette thèse
des enquêteurs huppignal est mis en
examen pour le meurtre de sa mère
personne ne se doute alors que l'un des
témoins les plus importants sur le point
de disparaître
21 juillet 2000 sur le lac du Bourget
ce jour-là Patrick Balan fait une sortie
en bateau en compagnie de sa femme et
d'une amie
pendant que les deux femmes se reposent
et prennent le soleil sur le bateau lui
décide curieusement de nettoyer la coque
et donc à un moment sa femme va entendre
un bruit un plouf la femme de ballon se
précipite elle ne voit plus son mari ni
sur le bateau ni dans l'eau les heures
passent et Patrick Balan n'aurait
apparaît pas monsieur Balan a disparu
dans l'eau
des recherches sont lancées pendant
plusieurs jours le fond du lac du
Bourget est inspecté mais on ne
retrouvera jamais Patrick Balan pour les
enquêteurs il ne peut s'agir d'un
accident
sur les novans que j'ai travaillé à sur
Chambéry chaque fois que quelqu'un s'est
noyé dans le lac du Bourget on la
retrouvait dit à part l'hypothèse d'un
malaise cardiaque brutal
la noyade me semble peu plausible à
quelques mois du procès de Hugues Pignal
la disparition de Patrick Balan intrigue
ce serait-il suicidé craignait-il
peut-être ce procès dans lequel il
s'apprêtait à être jugé pour complicité
d'assassinat et non-assistance à
personne en danger il va envoyer
quelques minutes avant sa disparition et
alors qu'il est déjà sur le lac un SMS à
sa maîtresse de l'époque qui pour les
enquêteurs ressemble à un SMS à Dieu
est-ce que c'est un SMS de quelqu'un qui
va se suicider je n'y crois pas
davantage monsieur Ballan n'était pas du
genre à se suicider en tout cas ni ce
serait pas pris de cette façon là très
vite une autre hypothèse est évoquée
aurait-on cherché à éliminer ce témoin
gênant
est-ce que cette disparition dans le lac
n'est pas aussi une disparition très
opportune pour faire pour faire
disparaître un témoin gênant qui aurait
pu être très important au moment du
procès qu'elle aurait été la couleur de
ce dossier en présence de de Monsieur
ballon qui savait des choses Patrick
Balan et il aurait été intéressant qu'il
a un peu plus loin dans ce dans ces
dépositions aussitôt les regards se
tournent vers HUG Pignal celui à qui la
disparition de ballon profite le plus
les enquêteurs évidemment apprenant cela
vont s'intéresser de près à cette
mystérieuse disparition il vaut
curieusement s'apercevoir que
uppignal a fait l'acquisition récemment
d'une tenue de plongée
aurait-il fait disparaître son ex
complice Balan cette thèse alimente
toutes les rumeurs
vérification faite à l'heure où Patrick
Balan disparaît huppiliale est en train
de signer son contrôle judiciaire sa
présence donc à la gendarmerie
d'Aix-les-Bains et donc il a comme qui
dirait un alibi en béton pour ne pas
être lié à la disparition de Patrick
Balan dernière spéculation celle d'une
disparition volontaire Patrick Balan
a-t-il voulu se soustraire à la justice
on s'est dit est-ce que par hasard il
aurait pas pris la fuite c'est tout est
possible dans la vie elle est tout à
fait plausible parce que
il y a du monde sur le like monsieur
Ballan est un homme qui est capable de
nager entre deux eaux après avoir pris
suffisamment d'air pour s'éloigner
discrètement du bateau c'est un homme
qui est capable d'être pris en charge
par un plongeur qui vient à sa rencontre
qui lui donne un peu d'air toujours sans
ressortir à la surface c'est un homme
qui est capable de
ressortir un peu plus loin derrière un
bateau qui se trouve à proximité lequel
bateau peut s'éloigner discrètement avec
Monsieur Ballan à son bord sans que
personne ne s'en rende compte ce n'est
qu'une hypothèse bien entendu
le principal témoin a disparu et le
dossier ne contient toujours aucune
preuve matérielle à la veille du procès
l'accusation est singulièrement
fragilisée et si Hugues bignal était
innocent
[Applaudissements]
27 mai 2002 c'est en homme libre occupe
Pignal se présente devant la Cour
d'assise de Chambéry et malgré la
gravité de son chef d'incubation le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
semble détendu
il rentrait de Corse il était
extrêmement décontracté
presque arrogant et il avait un
comportement assez
à ses étonnantes pour quelqu'un qui
était accusé du meurtre de sa mère il
avait un côté matamore
pas mal physiquement mais
je vous disais toutes les femmes seront
folles de moi oui c'était un
Blur
sur de lui par l'argent qu'il avait
si dans un premier temps Hugues Pignal
séduit le public il va rapidement
montrer un tout autre visage notamment
lorsqu'il évoque sa mère
pour ma part ce qui m'a aussi frappé
c'est que quand il parlait de cette de
la victime il disait jamais ma mère
n'est encore moins maman c'était elle
tout au plus on sentait que il y avait
pas de rapport d'affection particulier
avec la victime et ça c'est quand même
pesé assez lourd il me semble dans le
débat il se défendait fort bien
il cherchait surtout à convaincre les
jurés de son innocence mais sur le plan
des sentiments à l'égard de sa mère en
tout cas moi je n'en ai pas ressenti
pour Jacqueline Dufournet l'avocate
général de la cour d'assises de Savoie
Hugues Pignal est un fils intéressé qui
a tué sa mère pour échapper à une
situation financière catastrophique
durant les trois ans d'instruction qui
ont suivi la mort d'Anne-Marie Pignal
Hugues a dépensé près de 23 millions de
francs près de 3 millions et demi
d'euros
c'est vrai que j'avais beaucoup insisté
sur le côté patrimonial sur cette haine
que le fils avait à envers sa mère qui
n'attendait qu'une chose c'est que c'est
qu'elle décède pour hériter et puis
cette peur de cette vieille dame qui est
en fait a peut-être pas su entourer
d'affection son fils c'est possible mais
qui en tout cas
vivait dans la terreur et c'est les
éléments c'est sûr que j'ai sans doute
dû mettre en évidence dans mon
réquisitoire de son côté la défense de
Pignal met en avant l'absence de preuve
et pose des questions restez sans
réponse typinal avait l'intention de
faire du mal à sa mère de lui faire peur
simplement parce qu'il avait besoin de
d'être accompagné par deux témoins
autre question pourquoi Anne-Marie
Pignal n'a-t-elle pas dénoncé son fils
dans l'ambulance l'accusation à son idée
la victime a peut-être voulu épargner
son fils et par la même l'honneur de la
famille
[Musique]
peut-être qu'elle l'a reconnu qu'elle
n'a pas voulu le dénoncer en tout cas
elle a parlé elle a dit qu'ils étaient
plusieurs au moins de c'est tout
[Musique]
les débats progressent Hugues Pignal est
confiant peut-être un peu trop même s'il
n'y a pas de preuve dans un dossier il y
a ce qu'on appelle l'intime conviction
et ça dans ce dossier justement je crois
que ça a été très important parce que
Monsieur Pignal
ne s'est pas présenté devant les jurés
d'une façon très flatteuse donc il était
arrogant il était
prétentieux
pour vous dire il était libre il allait
manger en face du palais à midi
l'audience rentre à deux heures il
n'arrivait qu'à 2h30 3h45 donc tout le
monde l'attendait les magistrats
attendaient les jurés on avait
l'impression qu'il se comportait
enseignant et maître que tout lui était
dû après cinq jours de procès le jury se
retire pour délibérer
huppigne ALNA aucun doute ce soir il
sera acquitté d'ailleurs eupignal avait
prévu de convier une vingtaine de
personnes dans un restaurant situé de
l'autre côté sur le trottoir d'en face
de la Cour d'Assise pensant qu'il allait
sans doute fêter sa victoire devant la
Cour d'Assise 31 mai 2002 les jurés se
sont forgés leur intime conviction le
verdict tombe peut-on être condamné à 20
ans de prison sur un simple témoignage
sans preuve même si beaucoup d'indices
semblent vous accuser c'est ce qui est
arrivé à hucpinia l'enfant adoptif d'un
couple de riches industriel accusé
d'avoir tué sa mère adoptive dans sa
pignale et condamné à 20 ans de prison
un matricide qui selon le jury aurait
été commis sans préméditation
Jean-Claude Hardy pour sa parait COP
d'une peine d'un an de prison pour
non-assistance à personne en danger
surprise par cette décision Viviane
Pignal l'épouse de Hugues et révolté
c'est inadmissible que aujourd'hui
uxe soit condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
sur sur une intime conviction et sinon
sur sur des faits des preuves tangibles
un an et demi plus tard la condamnation
duc pignale sera confirmée en appel sont
pour vous en cassation rejetée pour la
justice française Hugues Pignal a tué sa
mère Anne-Marie le 31 décembre 1996
l'homme est incarcéré au centre
pénitentiaire de Moulins dans l'Allier
il devrait en sortir à la fin de cette
année
[Musique]